good morning believe nation today's
message is don't highly-specialized over
you Anna Wintour and I also know career
wise how important it is not to be too
highly specialized especially these days
in the world of media it is crucial to
have multiple interests and skill sets
to have tried and possibly failed and
many different undertakings the young
people that we hired today at Conde Nast
are fearless polymaths hardworking and
passionate creative and curious I think
the only thing that you should highly
specialized in is being you and I don't
think enough people highly specialized
in being themselves enough too many
people are copycats of other people and
if you continue to explore if you
continue to pursue passions if you need
to add your curiosity and learn new
things and see what makes you come alive
then you'll find that you have multiple
interests multiple passions that no
other person has the way you can combine
them is unique that nobody else can do
and that's going to be your magic that's
going to be your secret when you can
combine all the different things that
you love into one thing that then can
add value to the world that's a secret
sauce that nobody else can replicate I
don't think enough people spend time on
that I think too many people are exact
copies of others that there's not a lot
of difference between one financial
adviser and another financial adviser
but they're secretly is because both of
those financial advisers hate what
they're doing right now because there's
other things that they love but they
haven't figured out how to incorporate
it or the rules are such that they don't
know how to incorporate it or they just
feel like they're restricted but they're
not they put themselves in their own box
that they feel they can't break out of
and then they have to rely on their
hobbies in their side hustle and their
other passions but the secret guys the
secret to making it all work is
combining those things into one so you
don't have to have a side hustle or
other passions you bring it into your
work because that's how you will stand
out when someone
asks you at a networking a vendor at a
party what do you do I want you to have
a hard time I don't want you to be able
to enter that in one sentence because if
you have a simple answer to that
question then you're living a simple
life highly specialized in being you so
the question of the day today is I want
to know what is so unique and special
about you what have you combined that
nobody else can do in the world what's
that mix what's in your your mixing bowl
that nobody else has really curious to
find that what's that combination put it
in the comments below I'm gonna join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to Renault Marshall
thank you for know for picking up a copy
of my book and means a lot to me those
are you guys watching if you want to
change at a future shout out make sure
to pick up a copy of the book and email
in your receipt so that we can add you
to the list thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shock
events vessel